Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
I'm not mad.
I thought about Jujitsu going on here.
He's been going to salsa mustache
bodied up in this great head.
Mr. Steal your girl at that picture.
I wish I go. Okay, so here's the question.
We're in the round three now, right?
It's four 44 axes down to let's be,
I would say,
right if you had to look at this
scorecard, but interesting rounds, right?
The Max has got his,
both guys have gotten things off,
but all the looks fucking sensation to
the second round was little inch of the
first round. I was like, well,
Mexico, Brandon, please make
tee shirts. You're crazy.
I was interested in the first round.
I'm saying that first round though,
Max really got outclassed.
I don't think there was a big long
period the beginning of where everybody's
waiting for somebody to move to.
True and then although eventually
got the best of the exchanges,
he's just showing somebody trying to
get them back kicked back to what the,
Oh nope, he's laying them out. This is
some, oh, here's the other thing you got.
How many wars,
all those already been in
a real fight, like took a lot out of them
as the Chad Mendez thing though. I mean,
and also Connor, he's had
to Ricardo, Ricardo, lamas,
fight lamas had him on his
back and he's punched him.
Nick [inaudible] crazy. But he was
on antibiotics when he was a shit.
Yeah,
this Brennan please
both of them. Although it that
sweet need. I know. I don't know.
I'm hating on all though.
I don't get it. Oh,
I'm Max the wind for some reason.
You know what?
One of the best things that's
ever happened at a being
a commentator is learning
how to appreciate just a
performance [inaudible] favorite.
I always had favorites, man.
Always when I was early right hand.
I try not to now, but like if
somebody that I'm friends with,
like if cowboy fights, it's the worst.
It's hard. It's hard for me. Very,
very hard for me to call it. Your fights
were the hardest I've ever had to call.
Really hundred percent so hard I've
ever had a call. So you have to like,
oh my God, oh, he's
hurting. It's not over yet.
Oh my God. Oh my God. Oh.
Oh. She'll grappling going on, right. Oh,
let them up. I'll do is not let
them hire street. Oh my goodness.
Make him get up Max and knocked
him out. Oh, what heart? Heart.
Heart is right heart by Aldo
to survive this. He's too
his Jujitsu's but side controls.
Look at this live. Oh Shit.
So battered man.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
No more burger joints. Oh fuck man. Dude.
He might, you never know what the fuck
man
tried to sneak out the back door when
he's going to try and do is use. Oh,
he's got it. Oh my God.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
Move.
This is hurting a lot of time.
Oh my God.
What's rough is that? Oh,
that's a big job. He knows
what he's doing. Oh, head arms
arm's the wrong spot.
Oh,
if he just pours it on right now, he's
going to stop. Come on. No, no, no,
no. Oh my goodness. He's
defending. Oh my goodness.
Hey, cut me up. Cover up now. What? Now?
What? That's it. They can assess it.
He's going to say defend yourself.
Defend your notes. He saying I'm good.
My Rep didn't hear that last fight.
Oh,
oh.
Oh my God.
Holy Shit.
Hawaii finally got to the rural champ.
God Damn fucking Hawaii Shit.
Max Holloway.
You know what man?
Aldo,
he's shaking his head because he still
wanted to be able to fight and it's a
reference call to stop the fight and
he's very upset about that. He was stuck,
but man, it seemed legit to
me. That was a legit stoppage.
It seemed legit to me.
Oh, you know it's legit.
Eddie had criminal use. Legit.
Legit, right? Yeah, I do. Yeah,
I would. I would imagine. I like this.
I liked this. I liked it. That
big John. Let it go. That long
fight change. You rarely see he took a
beating for like two minutes straight.
Yup. Yup. Came back, man. You got
tagged. It's just sad. That white girl.
It's so hard, man. She sees what he goes
through, man. What an incredible fight.
Oh, let him jump in the
fucking flag. Flag, man. No.
There's this family that flew all the
way from Hawaii. Guys chasing my ma.
Where's the rock? What the
fuck? Yeah. Hurry up man.
You got a world champion in Hawaii.
Cleveland. We got a world champ.
Cleveland. We got weld
chesty pay. That's right.
That's one of my all time favorite. A guy
who just won the title things is steep.
Meo Chick did Cleveland's,
what is it about his kitchen situation?
He ran out onto the cage. He couldn't
believe it. After he knocked out,
we got a wheelchair.
Slash.
Kelly. Right? You like him? You like
machine gun Kelly? I don't want to
say something nice or say
nothing at all. Oh, hey, listen.
There's a serious movement in Cleveland.
Yeah, well listen, Cleveland is a,
I had a great fucking time.
We did the UFC in Cleveland just
a little while ago and I did it.
I did a show there in Cleveland.
I had a fucking great time,
man. They're fun, Dude.
That clip that city's coming back to life.
Hawaii Whitney's lucky come about.
Let's talk about, look at
this big bang. Boom. Come on.
Sign drops him with that right hand.
Nothing fancy. Is it the one to the one,
two beautiful timing though, man.
[inaudible] look at this. Look at that.
Oh my timing with that right hand
is perfection. He's on top of them.
Drop some bombs on them.
There was a couple of times in the fight
where it looks like it looked like Aldo
went out, put his will, his will and
his need to fucking get through this.
Like right there, Bang. Come
on man. Is to be Josie Aldo.
Just once in a kind of freak fight
with Conor to beat him like this.
I mean Max Holloway beat
the shit out of him.
He beat him in a way that
no one's ever beat him.
Blessed and kept going to him and he beat
them in a way that no one's ever beat
him.
Connor only beat him cause he caught him.
Max Holloway beat him down and beat him.
US beat him down.
He's got through the gauntlet.
How big is that tall or we can be Hawaii
and fighting his fucking shy and I've
been singing Hasees, Bj
Penn, and own that island.
I've been singing that kids
praises for a long time. He is,
came into the UFC super
for Josie to oh yeah.
Who's the guy in the background
holding that devastated like it's his,
it's the worst devastation. Devastated to
lose though, don't they? Yeah. Hey Man.
Hey Man. It is what it did.
Did a great job. He's a great
fighter. It is what it is.
This is fighting and people win and
people lose. And the the sport ultimately,
it depends upon these sort of fights.
It depends upon these all time greats
like Aldo facing some guy who's got the
solution to what that guy presents. Yup.
And that's what although did tonight.
How do you mean?
He went out there with all
of his championship medal
and he laid it all on the
line.
He fought his best and his puzzle
got solved by the new breed of,
let's hear, let's hear what
he has. It's condominium.
Both of these guys give us some
volume cause I know Harvey pause guys,
they beat him with a torn ACL at a
title wrapped around it a long time ago.
Still is incredible
diplomas or altering my lord and
savior. Jesus Christ. Second. Oh,
I got to love his son at home.
Maybe you got another know
on Baby Josh Holloway.
Great man. I love it. Yeah. George Rush.
Saint Pierre Inspired Nasser. No. Nah.
He's Hawaiian love over here on
the stand. You, you're on
your phone called you man.
I love you guys. But it made it made
you think I got any decisions exclusive.
No Feeder
John. Powerful. Shout out to Brazil.
Always a good move. Yeah, but they're,
they're pulling them. Well,
of course they're booing them.
They feel like the fight shouldn't have
been stopped because their guy got beat.
You're smarter than that.
Brazil started a little slow tonight
and round three when you got your slow
less. Why you gotta bring up, Oh shit.
Sarah,
where's my 50 kids?
Well, has 50 kids. You see
all the decision, right? Bang.
I'm a smart QC. Hawaii. Wow. That's
Tom UFC, Hawaii with very tough shit.
I don't know.
I don't travel overseas,
but I will fucking fly
to Hawaii in a heartbeat.
I will that make it happen.
Okay.